[Music]
Evon welcome to Copenhagen a political
scientist from Bulgaria that sounds like
snaps from Macedonia people of Western
Europe are not that concerned about
Eastern Europe and the ordinary West
German is not that interest in eastern
Germany a foreign world which is costing
the West German taxpayer far too much
money and which shows far too low
gratitude and votes for too many
populist s' these as I'm sure you've
guessed are not known words but the
beginning of a very long interview with
youth even in the German weekly Der
Spiegel
which came out a couple of weeks ago
obviously based on your book and the
point that the the Spiegel was trying to
make is obviously that many of us in
Western Europe are not that well
acquainted with Eastern Europe or
Central and Eastern Europe as we should
ride to call it or to paraphrase Neville
Chamberlain it's a mid-sized region of
which we know little and that is
definitely a wall you could say often of
prejudices although we are now in this
week marking the incredible events of
the very fact that the Berlin Wall has
now been gone longer than it's actually
been dividing Germany and Europe there
are many exceptions to this particularly
this audience many people really follow
also Central and Eastern Europe but
still if you look upon the debate at the
moment there are many things that are
posting us for instance why are so many
Central European citizens that worried
about refugees if you look upon the
number of refugees how did the
separation of powers suddenly sort of
lose its appeal in the region not the
question and then also when one studies
the Baris opinion polls you also mention
a couple in your book well you you end
up thinking hmm we apparently we do not
really agree I mean where's the threat
in Europe these days because if you look
upon opinion polls
I remember reading one Bulgarians
there is a major crisis in Europe
Bulgarians will obviously will
apparently turned towards the Russians
and they're not taught so NATO and the
United States of America these are just
some of the questions that will try to
cover in this in this conversation there
are many more and I'm sure that there is
no one with better and trying to educate
us on the region but I'm particularly
also the interconnections between East
and Western Europe a broader and number
of books here that I'll use interviewing
books that you have referred to in
Indian book and you've already been
introduced but when our sort of reading
up on you I thought it was also
interesting to say you were born in 65
in Bulgaria your father was a member of
the Communist Party and he was editor in
chief of a communist newspaper you
studied during the class not stays in
Bulgaria and you were in your final year
at the Sofia University in 89 so an 89
are here we have among us when the world
turned upside down and as a Russian song
writer has tellingly put it it had never
occurred to me that in the Soviet Union
anything could ever change let alone
that it could disappear but it did and
that office also opened many new
opportunities for you he went to Oxford
you set up a think-tank and now you are
in in Vienna you also a member of a
number of of think tanks for instance
European Council formulations where we
occasionally meet but then to start off
when one reads your book and one just
looks upon the front page I must admit I
was quite puzzled about the title after
Europe so is this the end with Europe
what's coming afterwards and then I
thought hmm then I saw what the German
title was that's called I hope a demo
room and that room in my mind somewhere
where it gets dark but then it can
actually then the Sun can rise again so
what's the point with the title isn't
this is good about titles authors never
put the titles titles about publishers
oh yeah
but my title was commercially so stupid
that I should be very good
to the public the original title under
which I was writing was called perhaps
book this is when you sent Bulgarian to
Vienna this is what's going to happen I
want first of all very much to say how
grateful I am for the translation and
for this opportunity because talking
about Oxford when I was there in 1992 I
remember complaining to an old German
professor saying listen for the last 20
years there was more than 40
dissertation being defended on Poland
and there was not a single one on
Bulgaria and he looked at me and said
but boy pond is a Korea Bulgaria just a
hobby
from this point of view basically having
the opportunity to talk and to do is and
listen from certain point of view I do
believe that European Union as we knew
it is not there anymore it's not a bad
news to be honest there is no the book
because of the title was read is
slightly more pessimistic than it is I
tell if it's an open end story but there
is one important difference between east
and west when we're looking at the
crisis and this is why it was so
important for me to bring this story
listen fall of us nevertheless why
politically stand we saw a major
political system basically collapsing
our in front of our eyes in the late
1980s in Bulgaria was not Poland
communism was stable as nature I
remember on the night when Bulgarian
Communist leader totally goof resigned
and it was the day after the fall of the
Berlin Wall in the restaurant of the
university there was a dinner and the
monk asked was the guy the man who nine
months later became the first Democratic
president of the country the only
well-known Bulgaria dissident of this
period George Elif and he was telling us
you a young you're going to see the end
of communism this was November 10 1989
ten months later he was a president so
from this point of view
time the periods in which time
really jumps many things that works
unthinkable after six weeks you have the
feeling that it was inevitable and in
Eastern Europe if we experts are experts
on something we're experts on fragility
from this point view it's very different
this is not about this is on the level
of experience that you know how quickly
things can change so this is why on the
eastern part of Europe you're going to
have a different reaction based on
different of experiences and not simply
of values and interests which normally
had discussed so you would rather prefer
the perhaps Berg title than yourself
perhaps book is for me was interesting
exactly because of the perhaps I said
there is a certain type of probably also
because of work because it's a the book
starts with in my good the best
description of the disintegration of the
Habsburg Empire that we haven't like
always it was not written by political
scientists it was written by a fiction
writer by Joseph wrote and this is the
story of his famous book Radetzky Marsh
so in the Radetzky March there is
somewhere in the remote garne Zone on
the borders of the Habsburg Empire a
telegram arrives and the telegrams
basically there is only one sentence the
hair of the throne have been
assassinated and then he tells the story
what happens among the officer corpse
the most loyal to the Emperor suddenly
hungarians started speaking hungarian
talking to their own and then the
solving officer started to be nervous
and he said stop speaking hungarian we
should all speak german and then the
hungarian said okay i'm going to say it
it on german i am happy that the bastard
is gone so from this point of view in a
certain way this is when in the time of
crisis people start speaking their
national language when this type of a
projects are getting into crisis
and I do believe that basically in every
crisis always the pew is let speak
German let speak English don't go on the
national languages but I do believe the
natural language is matters and this is
why by the way I'm really very I was
very moved by this translation because
if you're Bulgarian you believe that if
you're lucky enough you can be
translated in English in German and even
possibly in French the idea that you're
going to be translated in Danish never
comes to your mind and you cannot
imagine the pleasure of this this is
like Danish author being translated into
Bulgarian ask you sort of afterwards to
read it out in Danish but it has been
translated into you told me in nine
languages right yeah and the reviews
have they differed opposite been
different but I mean from east and west
could you see sort of a different
reaction in in Central and Eastern
Europe Russia from Western Europe the
strongest the most reviewed and the
biggest debate the book produced in
Germany and in fact the Germany was the
place where the book sold most copies
because of the link to the I don't go in
discussion I tell ya but also I do
believe that suddenly one important
thing has happened and probably this is
also the reason I am here there was a
period of time in which in the West
there was a feeling that we know what is
happening in Eastern Europe like it or
not and then suddenly many people had
the feeling that exactly they don't know
what is going on some people don't like
it other people but for the first time
there is a genuine interest because
after 1989 there was a lot of sympathy
and even there was a lot of kind of a
respect for what is to Europeans are
doing but there was no question there
was no puzzlement what they doing
people are happy they get free there is
no mystery in this in 1889 there was no
mystery because you were becoming like
yes what exactly also this was also part
of these two European discourse because
if there was one utopia of 1989 this was
the Utopia of normality we all the time
was saying that we want to be a normal
people living in a normal country which
in 1989 me
living like in the West even better in
the West so from this point of view I do
believe then suddenly for somebody who
is not visiting regularly scientists in
Europe who does not have son or daughter
married there and so on basically what
is happening there starts to look
strange why Central and East Europeans
who are doing fine because if you go
even on some of the economic explanation
about the crisis Eastern Europe does not
fit listen
Poland is the best performer in Europe
for the last 15 years economically the
country didn't have a recession at all
all this explanation that you can say
what is going on because of the economic
crisis does not work for Poland and then
people are going to say yes but it's
about social inequality but in the last
seven or eight years the social
inequality in Poland has been reduced
not increased so then suddenly you have
the feeling that you don't understand
something and I do believe always for
Germans it became particularly important
because they have East within the
country and this is the other story it's
not simply the division between many
countries this is the division within
the country when it comes to Central and
Eastern Europe I died I had the Polish
under the Russian translation is was
very kind of recent the problem with the
Russians is that more than anybody else
they believe that they know what is
going to happen and their logic is if we
collapsed why do European Union should
not do it too so from this point of view
in their case it's only true level yeah
me too and so in their case you have
such a strong trauma that they are
reading everything which is happening in
the European Union very much through
this experience to the extent that from
time to time that they are ready to help
this to happen but in many other
countries this is the first time when
crisis creating community of faith
suddenly and this is good about crisis
by the way suddenly financial crisis
comes and many Germans became experts on
Greek Poli economic policy
you really start to be interested what
they're doing how they're doing this and
then came the refugee crisis and Central
European start to be interested in the
German refugee policies so suddenly we
started to be interested in each other
and I do believe this is important in
Eastern Europe there is a feeling that
some of our argument was not hurt
to be honest part of it is true but the
reason it was not hurt is also on our
side because the problem we ceased in
Europe is the following
during the refugee crisis Central and
East European societies what the most
critical and to be honest quite hostile
to getting and receiving any refugees
and this was not going to be a huge
problem if there was any refugees in the
region but they were not so this is
physically there were people going
through the region but there were not
people in the region to the extent just
to give you a Hungarian opinion poll
there are more people in Hungary who
claim on the opinion poll that they have
seen non-identified flying objects then
they have seen refugees I'm saying this
not ironically because then I'm going to
tell you that there is something deeper
and serious about this reaction but
because of this situation in which you
do not have refugees but then basically
you're so hostile and then you have
countries like Germany Austria which are
receiving a lot of people basically
European arguments have been dismissed
very easily people cannot understand
what is going on and the explanation
become kind of a very cultural
explanations they're like these
communist legacy and so on and so on and
part of my idea in this in this book was
trying to explain explain does not mean
justifying there many things which is
happening in our countries that
personally I don't like there are many
governments in our country for whom I
will not vote but it means that we
should try to understand what is
happening on the level of society
because to try to explain everything by
demonizing one or another political
figure of government is my view is not
understanding but then going back shoes
of true the so what you just referred to
I mean basically sort of the end of the
of the first
when the First World War was such I
brought the sleepwalkers how Europe went
to war in 1914 also because Christopher
Clark was here I think two years ago
going through the book but your point
seems to be that exactly because Central
and Eastern Europe had a difference of
experience with regards to the first
world war that actually has an impact
now upon the refugee crisis that they
fear that well this was a time of Moche
of multiculturalism and so forth and now
this is getting back to us is that one
of the real points about this unity
about experts ability by the way I was
recently in Turkey and one of their
ministers at the sentence which should
be good introduction to what I'm going
to say he said you should know the world
war is over but we'll move on he's not
finished yet and I'm saying this because
in a certain way we have been always
focusing content the world war two but
in 1918 and this is a hundred years ago
something very important happened this
week continental European Empire started
to disintegrate the cap supports the
Ottomans and the Romanovs Russian Empire
but this was three totally different
logic of disintegration which developed
very differently there was hungry tears
the Hapsburg disintegrated and basically
the Central European nation states came
as a result of it the Ottoman Empire he
went through protectorates and so on and
now we see the crisis of the
post-colonial state in places like Syria
and in the Russian Empire basically the
Soviet Union managed to reconsolidate
territorially the Russian Empire why I'm
saying this keep in mind five things
when you're trying to understand the
reaction of Central European society to
the migration crisis first unlike most
of the West European society central
into European societies has a much
higher level of ethnic homogeneity they
have been purged by Stalin and Hitler
and as a result of it this society which
came as a very much multi-ethnic in the
post-world War one period after World
War Two and it
very ethnically homogeneous this period
in the interwar period for many people
was perceived this time of trouble just
to give one example in 1939 one cert
almost 40% of the population of Poland
have been non poles there was Germans
they were Ukrainians they were Jews
after the world 95% have been poles
it was not the post that purged anybody
this is quite clear particularly keeping
in mind the latest Polish legislation I
want to be on the safe side but the
truth is that as a result of it you have
a major change and during the Communist
period one of the major attempts for
legitimacy of the communist governments
was making ethnic homogeneity as a
source of legitimacy the second thing
that happened is none of the Central
European country has any colonial
history we had not been there
we don't have encounters with people
coming outside of Europe in a certain
way also there is no sense of guilt
generally basically we believe that we
had the biggest victim of history so
from this point of view we're not going
to allow anybody to compete with this
and certainly most of the national
identities of our countries has been the
result of opposing some type of a
Universalist project peter Habsburgs be
the Communists be the catalytic Church
it was to be it was in opposition but if
there is one thing that people to which
didn't understand was the demographic
dimension of it let's give you some
figures you know that you understand
what I am talking about in the last 25
years out of 8 million Bulgarians almost
1.5 million left the country living
somewhere in the West we are talking
about an aging society which according
to the projection in the next 40 years
is going to owes 27 percent of its
population when the migration crisis
started with the image of all these
people coming to the borders of Europe
and the idea that all these people are
going to come in to stay
what happened in Central Europe was
demographic panic suddenly you
discovered the mortality of your own
national community you start to fear
that probably in hundred years nobody's
going to speak Bulgarian you start to
fear that you don't understand the load
anymore
you're acting way exactly in a exactly
and I do believe this is very important
because the most under discussed issue
when it comes to the reaction of Central
Europe to the migration crisis is the
trauma of emigration a lot of people
left and to be honest it's not even
related only to the economic performance
for example the Baltic countries which
get very decent economic performance in
the last 10 years almost 10% of the
population left we are talking about the
very small nations why I am saying this
because and this is now mouth some
political science data the number of the
people the percent of the people that
left certain regions it's better
explanation for who is going to vote for
22 Germany than the number of the people
who arrived in certain regions this was
the most deep populated regions that
voted more for the alternative for
Germany than the regions in which more
refugees came so saxophones yeah and
this is extremely important because this
was this immigration element was not
part of the discussion
it is also new for Central and Eastern
Europe listen ten years ago for us
opening of the borders was the best
thing that has happened and if you go on
the opinion polls in Bulgaria if you are
asking people what is the best thing
that happened after the change people
are going to say opening of the borders
and then suddenly the best is becoming
the most threatening this same border
that you wanted to open appear to be the
thing that you fear and I was telling
this story because I was referring to a
very kind of well known book called des
with interruptions by saramago the
Portuguese fiction writer and he's
describing very well this situation in
his book death with interruption this is
the story of society in which
people suddenly stopped dying in January
nobody died in February nobody died in
March nobody died this was a true fact
people started to celebrate it was it
was real happiness and then first were
the insurance companies they said if
nobody is dying we're dying mhm and then
was the church if nobody's dying
nobody's resurrecting and then basically
you start to see how this which was the
best start to be turned kind of the most
threatening in the words to the extent
that at the end of the book the Prime
Minister goes to the king can set your
majesty
if we not start dying with we are doomed
I'm saying this because something like
this happened and this is why you know
that you understand the reaction you are
never going to understand it simply on
the fact how many people came you are
not going to understand is basically in
economic terms and you are never going
to understand it in economic terms
because Central and Eastern Europe needs
foreign labor at the moment the biggest
problem of Central European economies at
the moment is a very thin labor market
and by the way in places like Poland
according to the latest data they are
almost 1 million labour migrants from
Ukraine and nobody is talking about this
and the last is of course the muslin
factor which works very differently in
different countries because some of this
countries has been part of the Ottoman
Empire some of these countries where
Bulgaria has a Turkish minorities some
of the others basically have no
experience at all I'm saying all this
because this was a difficult story which
we never managed to put and the last
point is much more actual politics it
has nothing to do with history it has to
do with the fact that Central European
said you asked what the principle it was
to the dreamers you asking for
solidarity for policy you never
consulted with us if you did not consult
us on immigration on what else you are
not going to consult us and don't forget
their countries in which basically the
relations with Germany hippie
difficult and all these factors which
has their history which has current
politics ended up in a situation in
which Germans and central Europeans
particularly but it is also was the
other West European societies ended up
more divided by the migration crisis
then the north and the south have been
after the financial crisis so democracy
among the core sort of explanations and
our two countries are red basically in
2050 will be approximately the same size
because of demography and having been
sort of true eastern Germany last last
year several times I could confirm the
fact that I mean excited the link
between some demography people leaving
also this sort of as you call it The
Forgotten losers the feeling that will
detail open or they're forgotten all
about our problems whether it's the lack
of the of the internet or the local
doctor has moved and my kids have moved
and there is no company here and now
you're talking about refugees what about
my problems why don't you start
integrating me before you integrate the
refugees that was a very much the spirit
this was very much what I heard in East
Germany because it was before the
elections and what was very much
interesting and you can hear this in
places which are depopulated even if
you're successful there your success is
devalued because the question why people
want to leave change is very much the
situation and you know this there was a
beautiful joke in Bulgaria which
explains very much also some of the
other side of the problem and the joke
is about three persons being dressed
like the Japanese samurais and they're
walking on the streets of the city
somebody stops them and said who are you
they said we had a seven samurais and
we're here basically to make this place
a better place he said but why you only
three he said the other for a work
abroad I'm saying this because also in
this most society from time to time
you'll like a critical mass of people
and the critical mass of people is very
important because this is the problem of
the young generation and this is
something that I do believe we're going
cause what you realize talking about the
demographic stuff weird living in a
period in most of these countries but
this also true for Western Europe
because of the aging of society which is
just the mirror image of 1968 and this
is why I do believe to a certain extent
what we see now is a kind of a cultural
shift which is very similar at the same
time in a totally different direction -
68 68 the young the youth was a big
cohort though many of them the baby boom
generation there was simply many of them
they mattered very much in political
terms in economic terms they have been
shaping it listen in many of the
countries of our part also because of
the immigration also because of the fact
that even some people who has not left
but they can see the living if you're a
politician to be honest you should not
be interested in to use it does not make
sense electorally these people are
either living or not voting or not very
much interested in politics and this is
a small generation is a cohort it is a
small generation and as a result of it
also to certain extent what you're
seeing is a society in which the fears
the anxieties of the older generations
are very much reflected and represented
it and you should try to imagine how
much has changed for this older
generation because when we are talking
about my story listen I was 24 25 year
old in 65 for you the future is open you
did I have time to make many bad things
before you also basically think
everything through the times of the
opportunity open to you then put
yourself on somebody who has spent most
of his life during the odd regime that
basically have been told what is good
what is bad who also has achieved
certain level he is an engineer as a
teacher and so on and also because this
regime was very much based on a certain
type of economic predictability and
stability who knew how life is going to
look like and everything has changed
and this type of a incapacity to deal
with change in my view is becoming
critically important people became very
tired of change I just observe something
very interesting
everybody of you who know something
about Bulgarian history know that during
after the liberation from from the
Turkish Empire Turkey was not the
biggest friend in the way Bulgarian
society see it and then suddenly after
1989 in the last 10 years huge success
of the Turkish soap operas but this was
totally unexpected
why so i started very much to be
interested but I mean very popular among
coda but even younger generation and
then I discovered something which is
interesting people have been very much
kind of nostalgic for more conservative
society in which the father is the head
of the family and the family they need
to get all the time in Turkish films
they eating half of the time this is
their and when the daughter decided to
get married she's going to ask
permission so all this was there but you
don't know how to be nostalgic for the
old days without to be nostalgic for
communism because the old days in a way
was the communist period so then came
the Turkish soap operas and they were
giving this opportunity this is kind of
a traditional society in which you know
you understand Korea's pursecase a
definition of fatherland which I found
very important you understand what is
happening in Central and Eastern Europe
he said fatherland is a place which you
understand and where you have a feeling
that you understood and then for many
people in the region their own countries
are placed that they don't understand
anymore
and they don't have the feeling that
they understood and in eastern Germany
of course this was this was just in your
face very much very much I guess that's
one of the reasons why today when the
cocoa fur talk so the the Treaty of the
grand new grand coalition was agreed
upon there is now a high matte
ministerium sort of in in germany so
going back to fatherland going back to
we're discussing again german history
but also the very fact that many people
are worried that they can't recognize
their own country and so forth so that's
clearly confirms your point but going on
back to the policy implications of what
you just said okay so we have basically
no refugees in Central and Eastern
Europe we have still a very big refugee
problem in Europe what do we do then I
mean what are the policy implications
apparently it's not sort of the old
quota system that we've been debating
for very long time
so what then I presume common border
control I mean that should be a popular
but then also regional development
policy because I mean how do you deal
with forgotten losers probably not just
with open grants of your family
reunification
so it's interesting there was now a lot
of study being done on the rise of
populist parties and others one of the
most important findings across the
borders is that the cultural factor is
more important and the economic factor
there is an economic first Timothy
Garton ash article yeah a couple of
months ago it's cool to Stuart it's cool
to stupid and this is basically there
was a Harvard study being done all over
based on the the Michigan value surveys
what is important because culture
insecurity is much more difficult to
deal then with economic insecurity
because culture insecurity basically
come from very different sources one is
demography the other by the ways
technology lets tell because in the book
I'm claiming something that many people
basically believed was slightly too much
that there many things that probably
slightly too much but my major argument
was that the refugee crisis was Europe's
9/11 yeah what I meant is default what
do you mean listen 9/11 in the u.s.
3,000 people being killed in New York is
a tragedy but this is not the biggest
tragedy that has happened in the world
for the last 20 years under the level of
people being killed and destroyed why it
was so important because as a result of
it
the majority of the Americans saw the
world with different eyes globalization
which was perceived as something that is
positive beneficial working very much in
the American interest then suddenly
America discovered this vulnerability at
the backlash with against globalization
that you see now always direction of
President Trump basically started that
in numbers in terms of numbers the
refugee wave of 2015 is nothing
exceptional the people who entered
Europe is less than 1% of the population
of the European Union compared with the
number of the people that we have in
Turkey I'm even not talking about Jordan
and others it's much smaller number but
the effect was the same it put Europeans
to discover and to see the world with
different eyes and what Europeans
discovered is the following they
discovered simply that in the 21st
century migration is the new form of
revolution because if you are living in
a poor and badly governed country and
you want to change your life and you are
living in the world in which you have
internet and to know how the Danes leave
what kind of beautiful library they have
and so on it makes much more sense to
change the country than to try to change
the government your chances for radical
change is much higher and probably you
have noticed that one of the interesting
things that happened for this you don't
need Communist Manifesto
you don't need party you don't need
others in a certain way you need your
courage you should be ready to take risk
you need a google map and you go and
also even when you go when you come here
it does not mean that you ought to be
cutting with your society and community
because you can Skype you can fly this
is a very new situation and by the way
in 21st century if you see if in 20
century all revolutions has ideological
names Communist revolution fascist
revolution nationalistic revolution in
21st century all of them has a company
names Facebook revolution Twitter
revolution this was kind of a Google map
revolution when you realize that the
most radical change in their life that
people can achieved is by changing the
government the country not the
government then European Union
discovered itself as a counter
revolutionary power and secondly what we
discovered is that if before Europe was
an idea institutions we discovered
European Union is a place and by the way
place to be protected
before the refugee crisis the major
question was how to transform our
neighbors after the refugee crisis the
question is how not to our neighbors to
transform us and I do believe is a
result of it this is 9/11 for me is a
radical change that comes in the way
societies see the world nevertheless
that the political event
that produced this does not meet you
have kind of a historical consequences
by comparing with some others so this is
why for me and this is why I do believe
migration crisis is going to have a
deeper impact on the national politics
of European Union both east and west
compared both to the eurozone crisis
even breaks it Russian annexation of
Crimea so out of this for I do believe
that immigration crisis is going to have
the deepest impact it's going to change
most European national politics and you
can see this in Italy in the last days
basically if you see basically the shift
in the way the political parties move
what was that then the refugee crisis
for you the core sort of game change and
when you look upon European integration
because you're very critical of the all
the people who dealt with European
integration trying to come forward with
theories and as you basic rightly point
out I mean it was about the train ride
leaving the station and then it would
just go on there was not sort of this
integration was not part of the thinking
and you functionalist theory was about
spillover and so forth never spill back
as such and was that that the game
changer is that also why for instance
Mark Leonard when he wrote this book and
you know him personally obviously why
Europe around the 21st century that that
did not happen over the other sort of
aspects that the theorists sort of it
overlooked than the refugee crisis
listen in a certain way I do believe
that Mark's book is a very important one
because it captured how European Union
was seeing itself as a transformative
anyhow yeah but simply transformed if we
think ourself as the laboratory of the
world to come we knew that we're very
different than others we didn't have the
illusion
that all the world works like the
European Union but we knew that we had
the model of the future because we have
been post national post sovereign much
more integrated we didn't believe in
military power we believe in economic
power we believed in soft power and also
in the quality of life and European
Union had all reasons to believe that
this is the case you have the feeling
that the world is going in your
direction
and just imagine in a period of 10 years
after 2008 how much this was challenged
first we believe that military power
doesn't matter in Europe we know that
there is a military power we have an
idea not only authoritarian States the
United States was using military power
but we said in Europe it doesn't matter
and then come to me and the moment it
comes your major assumption that
interdependence economic interdependence
is enough to secure European Union is
not true anymore
and you have much more talk about
defence about military spending
then European Union discovered the need
of a power
secondly we never talked about borders
for good reasons by the way my major
argument is the book is European Union
is not so much now in this position
because of its failure you're there
because of your successes nothing can
hurt you as your success in time saying
because it was successful European Union
was so attractive that in a certain way
it was always bothering its future
members even Turk used to be a future
member so from this point of view
basically the problem of borders is not
important for you and the philosophy of
the European Union was ok what happened
after World War 1 when the European
Empire started to disintegrate the idea
was let's to change the borders you know
that you create more legitimate States
it was done but it created the world war
2 then the idea was we're not so much
trying to play with the borders but
let's exchange population let's go with
the ethnic purging in order to create
more homogeneous state and this is going
to create legitimacy and it didn't end
up well - and then after the end of the
Cold War the idea was do you know what
we're not going to expel people
we are now going to change borders we
are going to make borders and important
because this was the experience of the
European integration it worked and it
worked the problem is that did not work
on every border and then suddenly we're
discovering the problem of borders for
example in country like Bulgaria this a
major issue in country like Greece it's
a major issue and this is part of by the
way the major challenge for me in the
European foreign policy in other
European Union to be trusted by the
publics in such a different countries in
every single conflict you should adopt
the perspective of the most vulnerable
country so when you talk Russia you
should think like a pole and a boat when
you talk about Libya you should think
like Italian and from this point but
it's very difficult and I do believe
this is one of the things which has
changed people were not ready to do it
and for Eastern Europe what happened
listen in Eastern Europe still we trust
European Union in Eastern Europe you do
Central Europe you do not have your
skepticism
you have your pessimist people who
believe that it's going to end up badly
you have criticism but none of this
country believes that they're going to
prosper outside of the European Union
but part of the trust which normally
people had particularly in European
institutions particularly in Brussels
was trust based on mistrust and the
logic is the following we don't know
what they're doing in Brussels they
cannot be worse than alone and this is
true this is why European institutions
were more trusted than the national
governments and then came the migration
crisis and the logic change and the
logic is probably in Brussels they're
better but they care less for us and
this was a major change which can be
seen on the opinion polls suddenly
basically people started to trust their
governments which did not always liked
more than basically they start to trust
European institutions in this case the
consequences so from this point of view
when I said for me after Europe was we
should try to realize
the radical changes happened European
Union should be reinvented should be
rearranged it's not the same it does not
mean that after European Union they're
going to be no European Union and to be
honest also I don't believe that we can
return to the nation-states my personal
I hope I'm wrong but I do believe that
if something wrong going with the
European Union many of the member states
are going to face territory of
disintegration of their own and from
this point if you're Spain was a signal
you can see UK how difficult and this is
UK how it goes
Belgium is going to have a problem of
its own so from this point of view the
people who simply believes that if
European Union is not going to be around
and you're going to be back from where
you started I find this more utopian
than most of the utopias that we discuss
but going back to Central and Eastern
Europe and the policy implications of
your analysis I mean what is in the
answer there I mean with regards to the
refugee crisis and center in Eastern
Europe I mean what should French now the
new German government do I never
believed that quotas was an important
thing to happen first of all we're
talking about the very small numbers and
this was partly part of the scan that we
sent through Europe we have been
quarreling about 1,000 people this is
1,000 people and this was done and to be
honest I'm putting myself now being in
Austria saying this was through the eyes
of the Austrians which got a lot of
people per capita they get almost as
much as Germans and the Austrians are
looking to the Hungarians and the poles
and telling listen is this the same
people who expected us to meet them in
1956 in 1968 in 1981 and now when we are
meeting all these people so from this
point of view you're going to see a
situation in which no policy solution is
going to happen if these two type of a
misunderstandings are not going to talk
seriously and frankly to each other
because what we are seeing is on one
side basically in Central and Eastern
Europe many government which are trying
to break that base their legitimacy
saying that so we're anything these days
means resisting
European Union this is what it is and
European Union basically they're people
all in the West saying central Europeans
okay basically they're culturally
different they're not share our values
this cannot go like this it can end up
with some find of a two-tire Union and
so on but this is not what European is
going to benefit from in Central and
Eastern Europe also for the first time
and this is becoming a major issue the
idea of the West is a normal society is
challenged by certain corners you have a
much more traditionalist positions and
there is the other difference to a great
extent 1968 arrived in Central and
Eastern Europe in 1989 so you have one
generation difference and you're going
to understand this very much if you can
compare conservatives in the Western
Europe and conservatives in Eastern
Europe in Eastern Europe a classical
conservative leader is a full package
conservative he's conservative on any
type of minority you can imagine
religious ethnic sexual in Germany will
go in Netherland you're going to see the
leaders of a conservative party who
openly gay or doing this and that
so there's selectively conservative and
this is very much the impact of the
social and cultural impact of 68 because
in Central and Eastern Europe and in
Western Europe 1968 has two totally
different meanings in 68 it was about
solidarity of those who are not like us
very strong canticle on your moment if
you go basically to to the decent
authoritarian left and very much about
individual rights and very much about
minorities we all want minorities in
Central and Eastern Europe 68 in places
like Poland Czechoslovakia it was about
the national sovereignty it was about
resisting Soviet Union it was about our
national history when the Polish
students in March 68 went on the streets
and among them was some whom now we are
going to call the classical cosmopolitan
Poland like other Mitnick and others
they were there
the meats cabbage play which was talking
about the Poland and the power of Poland
against against Russia I'm saying this
because this is totally different
serenity of the individual which was
1968 in the West and sovereignty of the
nation which was 1968 in Central and
Eastern Europe now they clashed and this
clash is not going to be easily
reconciled in policy terms and I double
it from this point to view the tensions
between East and West are going to be
much more difficult as I told you them
between south and north and apparently
there's no silver bullet there no they
also because we have the other debates
with Center on Eastern Europe I mean now
let's also move to Hungary or Poland
political development i mean you write
in your book you you basically highlight
that parts of Central and Eastern Europe
have turned into a poster child of
Democratic liberalism how did that
development and yeah take on speed of
course its first of all is very
different from country to country there
is a beautiful Swiss joke which I should
share because otherwise my method
methodology is going to be
misinterpreted and the joke is about
three eight nine year old boys one
French one German one Swiss that started
to discuss where the babies come from
and the German boy said they come from
the sky and the parents find them in
front of the door and the French boy
became very kind of nervous and start to
ridicule Lincoln said were they come
from the bedroom where mom and my dad
are and everybody knows this but here
the Swiss boy became very nervous and he
said do not generalize it's different
from Canton to Canton
I'm saying this because basically it's
seen from the West political processes
in places like Poland and Hungary and
some other countries are very similar
political regimes are very similar in
many respects they're very different
and Mr Bond is very different than mr.
krichinsky it's not who is good who is
bad but they're coming from a very
different tradition they're basically
having a different idea of the state in
mind why I'm saying this because at the
same time there are three things that I
find as a common and to which I do
believe is important first try to think
about these government's if you imagine
what has happened in our part of the
world for the last 25 years
it works like a migration east migrated
to the west some did it individually but
most of us with our own countries which
means that we adopted legislation we
didn't discuss it because this is how
the club functions people basically went
through a very radical changes and these
governments in many respects he have a
problem which is well known in sociology
of migration which is the problem of the
second and the third generation the
third generation of migrants come and
the very process of integration is
perceived as success for people like
Havel he wanted to be more European than
Europeans and then comes the second
generation and second generation start
to discover tradition starts to feel
treated as a second class citizen you
have to have a level of resentment and
so on you have this secondly when it
comes to the rule of law what happened
was the following your great extent
politically what is happening in many of
these democracies is that for period of
25 years and this was part of also the
reason of success I told you that this
is the price of success that we are
paying now people had the feeling that
they can change governments as much as
they want in Bulgaria only once
government was reelected for 25 years
but they cannot change policies
and as a result of it what happened is
that many people in many of the
political scientists in the late 1990s
were very much saying to what extent
membership in the European Union is
consolidating democracy and on one level
it's true but on the other if you know
that you're member of European Union and
if you are really fed up with the fact
that you always vote for the different
party and you always get the same policy
then you start to vote more and more
inventively let's put it like this one
more creatively more and more
dangerously because you're not very much
afraid because you said at the end of
the day I can vote for this person who
is saying these crazy things but we
remember the European Union if something
bad is going to happen they're going to
take care so as a result of it we have a
process of radicalization of the vote
which was Pradaxa call so the result of
the fact to remember the European Union
and when they started to happen and also
this was because the process in Central
and Eastern Europe was some of the
political changes was not provoked by
the immigration crisis migration crisis
became a catalyst for many thing but it
started much earlier the other problem
was that for many people who wanted to
change the very idea of the rule of law
started to have a slightly different
meaning because many of these political
leaders mr. krichinsky has a theory of
political impossible ISM was telling
them listen all these people are telling
you that because of separation of powers
they cannot change anything give me the
power give me the whole power and I'm
going to give you a change that you're
voting for and this is a very different
understanding of political it's much
more majoritarian understanding of
democracy but this is a very strong
message because if you want change and
somebody is telling you the divisional
separation of power has become the alibi
for the elites not to change anything
but so what change that they won't
listen different people and this is was
different change many people want to
change in their lives basically they
have different expectations they wanted
economic change they wanted more money
many people has
wanted cultural change basically they
were very much disturbed but the
couturier basically that was listen for
example issues like gay marriage and so
on it's a very divisive in places like
Central and Eastern Europe but the most
important was that the message was give
the power to the executive if you want
change because the separation of power
is blocking any possibility of change
the only problem with this it is that
when you give so much power to somebody
you cannot be sure that he's going to
return it to it to you but otherwise I'm
trying to explain why societies which
basically start to work for change can
go and do things and this kind of a
shift to majoritarian understanding is
also part of this culture of shift and
backlash and talking about because if 68
was very much about individual rights
and the rights of minorities what we see
and I don't believe only in Central and
Eastern Europe is much more focus on the
rights of majorities majority is also
his rights it's very much the centrality
of the idea of way of life so it's not
that before there was no identity
politics and we have identity politics
now the problem is that before the
identity politics was only kind of
allowed to minorities and now it became
the the realm of majorities and this is
quite important and very well seen also
in the United States we are not simply
talking about majorities but majorities
which very often for demographic and
other reasons fear that they are going
to be minority in not so distant future
the white in the United States and you
can see the consolidation of the white
vote behind President Trump is part of
it so in the book are very much arguing
that that the group which is shaping
very much this type of a conservative
term is turn in European politics is
something that I'll label the threatened
majorities majority groups that started
basically to have the fears and the
sensibilities of minorities just to give
you one example to as a figure to
imagine what we're talking about there
was a study being done three years ago
in the United States do you in the
United Kingdom do
believe that you can influence the
politics of the government and then the
minority groups had the twice higher
positive reasons are to these questions
than the majority group and everybody is
saying rightly that is not true
still the Englishman can probably
influence the British government more
than some of the minority groups but
while the minority groups sees increase
of their power majority group sees
decrease of their power and this type of
a power dynamics in my view of very much
shaping politics in different places but
in Central and Eastern Europe of course
it is taking also much more
institutional turn and you can see now
in the debates between for example the
Polish government and the Hungarian
government and the European Commission
and others this is going to be a very
difficult question they're not going
when people said let's find the solution
solution is not technical solution
because just give you one figure from
from Poland majority of the poles
according to the opinion poll I'm
talking when it happened probably it
could have changed since then opposed
the decision of the government when it
comes to the changes in the
Constitutional Court Constitutional
Tribunal simply 55 percent were against
at the same time 55 percent have been
also against Brussels to tell Poland
what to do about the Constitutional
Tribunal and this is what is this is the
dashing and this is why I do believe
that in most of the cases what's going
to happen in Europe is going to be
solved very much on the national level
but if one follows that line of thought
with regards to sort of the EU more less
than being the safety net below the new
sort of mr. strongman in Central and
Eastern Europe whether it's now Albarn
or whether it's kasinsky doesn't really
matter and then watch it what should the
EU do then remove the safety net I mean
that's part discussion at least article
7 suspending the membership rights is
sort of part of the debate now or if
again if only reads the new German
government what they now suggest 'san
to have a linkage between the EU budget
and countries that do not live up to the
various Democratic rules or would that
be the completely wrong approach by the
European Union to be honest I don't like
very much the idea that you try to
basically weaponized transfer of money
and I'm going to tell you why one of the
major thing that you're going to start
to hear from Central Europe and probably
many of you are going to be shocked is
the following everybody is telling how
much money went from the west to the
east but what about the money that East
Europeans invested in educating the
younger generation who now came to work
for example to Germany or Denmark and
people were now started to calculate how
it is I don't believe that European
crisis in a certain way can be solved is
calculation on both sides there is
something wrong when everybody just
feels as if European Union is taking out
of you
Central and Eastern Europe benefiting a
lot we have been change our countries
not for everybody and so on and I double
if it was a positive change and secondly
what I would say is none of our
countries is going to do better outside
of the European Union I can try to
imagine the sunny perspective that
Bulgaria is going to come off imagine
that we are living here a peon Union and
what we are going to enjoy turkey Russia
everything nearby so from this point of
view this is and many people know it
very well but they should be much more
political calculation how to be equal
the idea that they're not grateful is
wrong
and by the way West Germans now are
paying the price of the thinking in
terms of being grateful and not grateful
because where Germany put a lot of money
in his Germany no doubt about this what
they decided to do and the money and so
on but at the same time when you go to
is Germany they're going to tell you
that 70% of all professors in the
university of leipzig are coming from
the west so from this point of view the
idea of political equality and how it's
going to work and basically trying to
have much more sensitivity for the
problems of the other side in my room
matters
my personal understanding is that's
paradoxically what is happening in
European Union is that we have four
crises each of which could have
destabilized dramatically the Union but
over play of this crisis stabilize the
European Union for the last year they
have this famous dance in the nineteenth
century Vienna which is called quadrille
way all the time changed the partner and
I'd have something like this happened in
European Union look how the crisis
helped each other for example during the
financial crisis it was very important
from the German point if you'd not to
change the rules because they were right
that if you start signaling changing the
rules basically don't know how the euro
is going to survive but for the Greeks
and the Italians they absolutely right
saying listen according to these rules
we cannot grow simply and then came the
refugee crisis and because of the
refugee crisis the decisions were taken
that the money that is spent on the
refugees are taken out of the 3% budget
deficit and then suddenly you get a
flexibility that you didn't have before
because how much you're spending on
refugees is a political issue it could
be creative accounting I'm saying this
because suddenly you have a much more
room for maneuvering without changing
the rules or when people are saying
fishing crab group it's going to be
totally consolidated and tacked against
Brussels and others yes on some issues
like migration but go to the Russia
crisis when it comes to Russia the views
of hungry and poor very different angry
much more friendly relations to Moscow
Poland not so friendly so from this
point of view strangely enough all the
crises are dividing European Union in a
very different groups and it was this
division that created political space
which allowed the European Union
basically to survive and also what I do
believe is important is that again to
certain extent the United States and the
United Kingdom helped very much to
Europe to be consolidated because as a
result of the elections of President
Trump something important happened not
only on general level but many of the
populous
parties that the previous year have been
moving to the center they were having
the feeling that their time is coming so
they were trying to get much more in the
mainstream but then President Trump
basically one running out of the center
so some of these parties for example
when marilla Pen said that she wants to
leave the euro I have been reading the
opinion poll listen there is no single
data that suggested the DISA popular
idea but she said that if she is not
going to do something which is
symbolically very radical people are not
going to follow her but people didn't
follow her because people were not there
and from this point if you this relic
Alizee ssin of the populist parties led
to the situation in which there was a
moment and the initiative was taken and
here I do believe present my chrome did
something which was important for Europe
and this is that he was the first one
that created a pro-european populism
when people are saying that McCrone is
an anti populist candidate it's not true
to be honest but he for the first time
managed to create the idea of change
before if you want change you should be
against the European Union he basically
married the idea of change and the idea
of European Union and he has this case a
very important political consequences
you're taking the initiative what is
funny is that people normally also I do
believe micro showed something very
important also that when we talk all
this talk about Europe everything is
about institutions everything is about
structural things where is a personal
talent and there is luck because he was
lucky like hell and from this point of
view luck matters in politics personal
initiative matters this is not a chess
game and from this point of view to try
to reduce everything to policies and by
the way policies is not only what people
do policies is also how they justify the
action one and the same Act is a
different policy based on your
explanation and justification why you're
doing this in your book you also quote
the captive mind where you write man
tends to regard the order he lives in as
natural and then you quote male
the pen the european union is dead but
it doesn't know it yet reading your book
you kind of have sort of the very much
2017 sort of mood that was a time where
if you've been here a year ago before
the book was written we would have
discussed the domino effect of first you
would have builders in netherlands after
we had brexit trump and then you had
builders and you'd have the election and
in france and then you would have the
election in germany and certainly well
the year this integration trade will
definitely have left the station as
yourself right in your book now you seem
self to be arguing in a slightly more
optimistic way was that what did you
miss there was that time that donald
trump effect as far as i could hear that
you were saying that he at least had an
effect upon some of the parties or would
you say that you didn't miss anything
when you everything but first of all
when it comes to optimism the demands
from the bulgarian sent expectation
should not be high there was a study
being done and quoted by The Economist
about how optimism relates to your
economic situation and so on and it
appeared that there were three groups
the optimists the pessimists and the
Bulgarians but Bulgarians were very much
more pessimistic than their GDP is cause
you don't have anybody progeria called
happiness like me I'm much more hopeful
pessimist so where I stand for first of
all I don't to be honest even then I was
not I never believed that lopen is going
to win builders but at the same time I
believe that there is a major
transformation of European politics
which started and I don't believe that
the McCrone is the enter the populist
wave I simply don't buy this and it's
not simply because of the Austrian
elections I do believe Italian elections
are going to demonstrate it and
certainly also I don't believe that very
understanding of how people understand
what is the populist wave we managed to
basically reduce the fear of populism to
the rise of a certain parties but if you
see
of some of these parties you can see
that we have the emergence of a new
consensus on many issues immigration
being one of them so Austria in 2017
elected the green president and
basically didn't allow the candidate of
the of the freedom party to end
elections a year later
basically you have a Santas far-right
government and in a certain way on many
issues the difference between the two is
not very big why I'm saying this because
unlike many people who read this very
much as the return to the 1930s on this
I am NOT as pessimistic for many reasons
but we have them I important for me
first economic situation is very
different than nineteen thirty's only
people who never read history can
compare the way people live now with the
way they have been living after the
Great Depression secondly nineteen
thirties Europe was populated by
ex-soldiers all these people has been
fighting all these people knew how to
shoot and all these people had a very
high tolerance for violence because of
so code in history it's known as the
brutality hypothesis and certainly in
nineteen thirties both the far left and
the far right have been revolutionary
forces they have an idea of the future
if you see the Communists and the
fascists they didn't like the people in
the way they were they had the idea how
to remake them it was a pedagogical
project but it was very much future
oriented look now the level of violence
is very low compared to many things and
secondly if you see - the populist
parties they don't have a pedagogical
ambition just the opposite their major
messages I like you in the way you are I
don't want you to change you're very
stupid I like you like this now no I'm
saying this because in a certain way
this populism very much framed for the
consumer age and many of the populist
parties treat their voters saying listen
I'm your waiter just order me and I'm
going to bring you what you want I'm not
going to tell you this is bad for your
health or this just tell me what you
wanted you're going to have it
so why I'm saying all this because I do
believe for me the parallel which I'm
going to use is much more than 90
seventies and he is the big challenge to
Europe in 1970s European democracy was
in a real crisis I was not being neither
very much around particularly not very
much around in Western Europe but if
you're going to read the 1973 report the
crisis of democracy after a lateral
Commission you're going to see what
people were talking about the idea was
that the institution's so totally eroded
that a new adversary class is appearing
that the students and the young people
don't share any model values of the
previous generation and then 20 years
later the ante system radicals of the
1970s ended up as ministers in German
French and other governments as a clerk
official so in a certain way the biggest
success of Western democracies in the
period of 70s and 80s was the
radicalization of certain generation but
at the same time many of the issues that
these people cared about entered the
political realm women's rights
individual rights so there was a major
cultural change environmental issues one
of the reason now the Green Party's are
not doing well because everybody went
green so from this point of view what I
do believe and this is going to be is
now you have this wave coming from the
right and this is very much about the
rights of majority
it's about belonging it's about other
famous yeah and the problem is can the
liberal democratic institutions
particularly when the European Union is
much more integrated now than it was
then be able to socialize and eradicate
some of these people in the way it did
with the wave of the 68 because probably
some of the things that they are saying
makes sense obviously borders is an
issue you cannot simply say we have for
open borders but you can also not close
the borders simply because there is no
in the world close border the only calls
border is on the graveyard between this
world and the other one
so from this point of view obviously
there going to be something which would
look as a political compromise but how
it worked and our our institutions ready
to do it and what kind of institutions
were talking about because technology
also is changing a lot I was talking
about the demographic fear and
demographic fears are very typical for
Central Europe but I do believe that the
next crisis is going to come from the
Western Europe it's going to be about
technological fears United Kingdom
survey claims the United Kingdom
government that in the next 30 years 43
percent of all the existing jobs in the
European Union are going to be ultimate
ice-t-- is it true or not I don't know
but I'm giving you in order to get the
skill and what is interesting most of
this is going to be on white collar jobs
one for example of the group's because I
have a 16 year old daughter and she's
trying to decide what she wants to study
and she was interested in law and I'm
just telling her according to this study
the lawyers are not going to be in high
demand because they're going to be a lot
of legal software but in a certain way
how this is doing and I do believe that
this type of a crisis in which it's not
difficult to imagine the world or
technologies for example normally ten
years ago personally I believe the
technology is a natural ally for
democratic societies and to be honest
I'm not sure anymore for example if you
see China not Russia Russia is not
sophisticated on this but Chinese highly
sophisticated one of the biggest
problems those retiring regimes is that
you don't have an access to your
relevant information
because you should rely on the police
information and police institutions has
the tendency to distort them everything
that we know from literature now is the
big date is not exactly like this the
level of surveillance capacity of the
new technologies the level of social
control so we obviously facing a society
about which we don't know much and here
is talking about my fears for the you I
have one major fear of the you European
Union started with a political project
which was very much based on
experimenting this was the most
courageous and brief experiment
that the war in which most of European
society is basically were killing each
other till yesterday you're starting to
create a political frame in which
they're going to live together if you're
going to see with the eyes of the people
that have been going out of the war this
was extremely courageous now I don't see
a lot of appetite for risk taking on the
side of the European politicians I the
word experiment for example in 1990s was
a dirty word in Bulgaria they said who
wants to experiment to go to your doctor
so from this point of view I do believe
that what is changing is this in order
to be successful in this type of a
period you need a much more experimental
understanding of what is going on why
what I am seeing basically is very
strong tendency particularly on the
level of the European institutions
things work well it's enough to continue
doing what we are doing we have now
economic growth and economic growth is
going to be enough you know that you
really do to Mai's the European Union
here I'm pessimistic
I don't believe economy growth is going
to be enough first because we don't know
for how long
secondly if the cultural anxiety is at
the center economic growth particularly
growth of 1 to 3 percent is not the one
that can deal with this where I'm
optimistic I don't believe that every
kind of a revolution produces a certain
type of a counter-revolution
but the counter-revolution mainly serves
to legitimize some of the gains that
cannot be reversed anymore and from this
point of view and I have this in the
book when we talk about Habsburg Empire
now everybody is interested how it
collapsed but many historians claim that
if it was not for the war it could have
survived and the most important is
hundred years before it collapsed
everybody expected it to collapse so
probably for the European Union more
interesting question is to answer is why
it didn't collapse for these hundred
years so probably this is going to give
us a better chance to understand because
mine is the capacity to survive is the
major source of legitimacy
of any political project the more crisis
you survive the more legitimate you are
and from this point it will go through
this crisis in a better shape because
people start to basically to take your
existence is natural this is what
happened to the nation-state
if you see in our countries in Central
and Eastern Europe how much we basically
believe that the nation-state is the
natural order of things
here you ask yourself for how long most
of East European have been living in the
nation states on their own for a very
short period of time but you have the
feeling that this is the natural form of
political existence and this is why for
me capacity to survival is so important
and Machiavelli has this beautiful quote
I'm telling not quoting but he said for
every ruler even for good Prince their
good time at that time and nobody can
simply avoid and escape from the bad
times the problem is here you manage to
accumulate enough of a positive
sentiments during the good times in
order to survive the bad times has a
chance but that done completely explains
your sentence it's quite possible that
European public's will become more
confident about the EU not because it
has become better but simply because it
has survived as well before we end I
just wanted to ask you about Germany
because I was struck by the again by the
interview in their Spiegel which I have
translated from German into English and
you say following Germany is now one of
us for a long time this country was
living in a totally different world than
major parts of Europe as if Germans were
on holiday and the others were going to
work he was a paradise the economy was
stable the confidence in the
institution's political parties and the
media was impressive when you as Germany
are living in a different world it is
difficult to understand the problems of
others indeed the
were of the opinion that they had
nothing to do with the problems of the
others quote unquote
I was struck by that because it seemed
to me is if you unlike many other people
who are worried about that Jeremy now
has alternative a torchon a populist
party that this could lead to Vienna or
whatever he also read the German press
you seem to take the different angle
that this could actually change the
German policy and make Germany or maybe
more normal or lease more sort of accept
more problems of other countries you
also refer to dislocate and now you also
have afferent gate with the with the
monkeys and and Fabi and so forth so
yeah just yeah what could that lead to
more of your optimism
strangely enough maybe but yeah first
though I'm not so courageous to commend
German in your presence but no but my
feeling was there was something
particularly about German as in Germany
as a leader of the European Union in the
last 10 years the years that have been
very difficult for others were the best
years for Germany look at the financial
crisis it was financial crisis fathers
Germany benefit I'm not by the way
blaming Germans as you know and but
simply the truth is the Germans
benefited from it and they benefited not
simply in financial terms but as a
result of the financial crisis some of
the young talented Portuguese Greeks and
others ended up working in Germany not
simply that they get a good migrants
talented but also from the cultures that
they understand better so as a result of
it because Germany was doing fine the
the feeling in many Germans was that
it's enough others to do in the way we
are doing decent everything is going to
be fine and then suddenly you realize
that even holidays not forever because
the results were surprised for many and
secondly basically when you talk about
others being corrupt and Trust and so on
and solve the big Germany industry some
of the scandals of course shows that
basically corruption is much more spread
in Central and Eastern Europe
particularly in some countries but it's
not something that Germans don't have an
idea about and then suddenly I do
believe the Germany developed
much more empathy to the problems of the
others I do believe that German is going
to be a better leader in its current
form in which they start to doubt some
of their own successes to ask tough
questions about themselves to see her
problems then in a previous period in
which they had been very much
celebrating themselves and this is very
important because without Germany Europe
is not going to function from this point
view Bulgarian experience is very
different we are much more kind of a
German friendly than some of the other
Central European countries having
different experience and so on but I'm
saying this because also the German
French relations changed listen France
suddenly got a different self-confidence
not that so much change in the French
economy but people start feeling
different and mr. Makran looks like a
leader and so on so there was a major
dis balanced between Germany and France
which was also not very well for the
European Union because France was not
standing only for itself but it was a
certain representative of European sows
in the way it was created so now first
we have a much more diverse leadership
and also I do believe that in a strange
way
Germany better understands Eastern
Europe when you see how people vote for
alternative for Germany they better
understand some of the problem of the
others and even if you see basically all
the compromises that went with the grand
coalition and others Germany realized
that it cannot succeed being very
different than the other parts of Europe
so is it going to be good or bad this is
the problem with optimism we always can
find reasons to be optimistic
the only problem is not to overdo this
because if we're going to overdo it that
is that this is natural it's not nature
it's going to depend on people it's
going to depend on the Chancellor it's
going to depend on the Social Democrats
it's going to depend on others it's
going to depend on the chrome so from
this point of view if there is one thing
about the book is politics is not like
algorithm they're also about people and
how they feel and what they're going to
do and what they believe in
and from this point of view yeah
probably I'm optimistic than a year ago
but I'm not buying for a minute the idea
that European crisis is simply over and
everything is over and now is McCrone
and to his miracle the only thing that
we should do is basically to forget and
also the world have changed a lot and
the change is much more deeper even when
probably they're going to be different
president of the United States United
States is not going to be back where it
was and China is not going to be back
where it was
and Russia is never going to be back in
the 1990s so from this point of view
everything is changing and we should
enjoy it and you still hasn't dealt with
the refugee crisis anyway so yeah a
changer is still there exactly and yeah
and it can have a kind of a new peaks at
any moment yeah well we could go on
forever but that's not possible
you mentioned the good and the bad times
and obviously this has been a good time
you are a good time for us it's not sure
that it was a good have to ask them
and you are in the country you are in
the country of our perceive country
Africa right
hence Christian Anderson and now we also
want the the tennis tournament in in
Australia with Cowell universe sake so
obviously we bought you not to wear not
a book about that but I'll talk about
sugar so you can remember this the
session and who knows maybe when we have
the next sort of version of after Europe
you will then also elaborate on the
concept of ticket so thank you very much
thank you very much to the publishers
[Applause]